like beach wave pressure Mitch register
that's Crisco people pay hundreds
dollars to look like and I woke up like
this
yeah I could tell you know you know how
you don't you don't have to convince
anybody you woke up like watch watch me
what the [ __ ] we do you even [ __ ]
invite her here she just came out of
that garbage can right anyways guys
today is gonna be a very very fun
episode I got a couple of special guests
with me
we have dolly right here and we also
have Julie [ __ ] Zahn
Julie's purpose here today is to teach
us a little bit of [ __ ] whoo
shoo I had no idea she was doing this
because I chose not to talk to her for
two years
giving him the silent she gonna know it
hopefully works the other person knows
that you're giving them the silent
treatment
so she comes up to me right she goes
okay you know what silent treatment over
I'm like since when she was so [ __ ]
mad because she wanted me to feel pain
from the silent treatment but I actually
didn't give a [ __ ] about her so it's
like ah look at this what is this it's
paint I'm an artist
what did you think it was something that
was on your face earlier today doli doli
want you explain to people who you are
what you do so I'm a coal thread and I'm
based in Hong Kong and I came to LA to
meet David so we can do some things
together but both there we just came out
in June we make videos about food
culture travel all the Chinese and Asian
things we love our food we love our
people and we're from all over I love
working with companies that [ __ ] with
anything Asian and they don't think
about both rates even though they're
like Chinese centric it doesn't just
stop with like Chinese culture it's like
everything Asian so why not mix that
with a little bit of Davis so comedy
branding you know what I'm saying
how [ __ ] with gold just to give you
guys a heads up she's been doing wushu
for about a year and a half so not an
expert I want to say this right now she
is she says that she's an expert
Julie want you to tell us what will Xu
is who she literally means martial art
in Chinese and so it's like kung-fu
we're gonna focus a little on northern
style or like lungfish Chong tread look
at that I speak Chinese I'm so Egyptian
so anyway I'm learning from legit people
and I come from like a dance background
so hopefully it's like gonna translate
but I'm not a master so no haters helps
it open up to you you know what let's
start with horse stance we're gonna hold
that for 30 seconds
but porcelain around a horse dance is
like one of the main stances of wushu
and it makes it very sturdy so you want
your feet wider than your hips for sure
and then bring the knees down and then
keep your foot down lower
I cannot go lower a big part of like
wushu kicks and a lot of the moves that
we do is there's a lot of slapping we
call those golden bags conditions your
hand so that when you punch people
it doesn't hurt because you've already
slapped it perfect and then just make
sure you slap it down terrible [ __ ]
teacher good good here you go what the
[ __ ] where's Bob [ __ ] sandwich I love
you Mary but fun sometimes
evil laughter and then you're gonna be a
butterfly
all right [ __ ] you got to leave in like
ten minutes I'll teach you some more
[ __ ] and what you do is it makes like a
tiny circle yes it like comes down on
the inside so imagine if there's a line
right in front of you you want to start
with your leg on the right side of the
line and then end on the left side of
the line so you make a tiny little
circle inside and as the foot comes down
it hits your hand right there
don't it's all like who shows about
hurting yourself much like every Asian
martial art I'm so happy oh my god so
much joy oh my god many one since this
is started I'm sorry he sucks
wow thanks teachers payback for the
syllogism you didn't know I gave him so
as it comes down like don't what I'm
saying
I [ __ ] dope combat you stay right
there I'm not gonna kick you right so
would you start off especially like
gonna tip on those tests healed in this
way next time I'll bring the homies
martial club they couldn't come - I
brought her Julie has an audition that
she has to go to so she has to bounce
but guess what we got to go get some
damn food so
this is gonna be her specialty we're
going to have a Sichuan restaurant I
don't give up in Cantonese I can't even
read this but I'm illiterate actually I
can only speak Chinese if you guys
haven't had likes to chew on food before
it's it's very unique
there's it's spicy but it's kind of a
different kind of spice and you know how
people describe it is like a numbing
spice now every time I've eaten this I
[ __ ] on a dragon out of my [ __ ]
this stuff okay it tastes really good
but if you don't like spicy food I don't
think this is like your cup of tea so
you said that you actually went to this
one yeah actually yeah one of the first
things we did for gold thread was to
actually go to Chengdu and cover as such
one this has become so popular I think
the food itself has become so popular so
many places and big cities are opening
up lexicon places for some reason like
even the food in Asian culture every
time you want something good there has
to be paid first and that is the
definition of Sichuan no trivial though
peppers are not needed to tighten it the
original original citron food is just
nothing there's just peppercorns and
stuff oh yeah I am and then through
whatever globalization then you can look
like one Asian guy that was a this hurts
a lot yeah I could so what is what is
the first upset we're having right now I
need the coal dude oh so that's really
make this for like stitch oneself ooh -
because you got everything else like
super spicy and hot so off you want
something cold noodles about salad with
the [ __ ] stuff I was talking about
before a lot of times they have like
young fund which is like a cold noodle
with like a hot spicy stuff on top so
you thought that makes em about or so
I'm open I heard you could just smell
like this delicious aroma coming over
look at that like salty savory spicy
okay here we go it's the cold noodle
nobody can tell that they actually make
these noodles in house cuz they're like
that okay and stop that spicy is good
though it's got a little bit peanut a
little bit of meat I like cold noodles
like in Korean culture we have a bunch
of cool new dishes and I know a lot of
people kind of have like this like a
version towards it they're like I don't
want my noodles cold I love cool it's
like the [ __ ] make it go I realize that
Korean food is spicy path my [ __ ] is
delicious it's sweet yeah
next up we have a lava soup what is the
component in this cut all I see is chili
oil and a Friday look like there's
peanuts a fried egg
sweet and sour is actually one of the
flavors of citron more so sour than
sweet so don't think like General Tso's
chicken baked more like
vinegar and a little bit of sugar
you know that noodles actually kind of
earthy tasting there is not like a
monkey that looks very silky watch that
cascade it's like Pantene pro-v hair
it's not as bad as that yeah and it's
not spicy is that chili oil it coats it
right when you pull it out so whatever
is like pulling on top when you feel
that new up you're gonna get that chili
oil around it but I like that sour bit
yeah it's pretty [ __ ] off yeah you
see you they got like mung beans and
peppercorns peppercorns are actually the
citrus family so they're kind of like
baby blinds my [ __ ] nose is sweaty
it's so good though I think that's like
the tree we're like good food is when it
hurts you and you still want more it's
like relationships you know I mean like
your girlfriend keep breaking your heart
but you keep going back for that ass so
third dish that we got the stairs so
awesome but yeah that's what we called
it Chris okay what do you call it
it's like true like fusion food for
great people and we have our like black
bean version of it and when I first had
it like this style I was kind of blown
away like the similarities but it was
still different enough and I can see
we're like the roots God started mixing
in different cultures so we kind of like
work with the Korean palette versus like
the Chinese fella that's the matching
cousin
with all this Nevada just what you gotta
[ __ ] me here we go downtown me in in LA
oh that's super soy sauce II like that
it's salty bailamos slow sauce flavor
which probably recognizable like Korean
dog and - it's just got more of that
saltiness sure like the Korean version
has a lot more intensity from the black
bean - yeah he's a little bit of that
beef
oh hello my friend
I gotta get another if I got to get
another bite and invited that does it
does it taste like Tonto man would you
call this downtown yen if you know it
you know what I smelled it did smell
familiar yeah
but the taste is complete
mMmmm yeah that's good
I gave it a David soul platinum stock
for Davis oh is now melting before my
eyes next up we got the Tonto which is
like a very typical situation long time
it really is just a watch on but the
citron take on days of douse it in chili
oil
[Music]
how's that that's bad I was I actually
prefer Hong kong-style one time oh [ __ ]
in this restaurant but I get kicked out
I love it it's meaty
it's like a ravioli my hands not spicy
it's just had like really good chili
flavor to it and for our last dish we
have another coupling dish different
kind of dumpling this is the one that
they were recommending what yeah so they
were recommending this because they says
what are their signature dishes but you
didn't even tell from the skin of this
is very different from the wonton I
think it's a much bigger skin they fold
it differently this one is like a
Halfmoon shape whereas the wontons look
just like this is very Korean Japanese
reminiscent so like Korean people like
the mandu that I had which is like our
dumpling was shaped like this
how's that for you oh is it yeah it's
good this is really testing my damn
chopstick skills it's embarrassing me
Cayman drippin I got the wrong one
what have I done I know but what have I
done
go come here and get this one the tester
is really good too
for something sweet and spicy but this
doubling the the EE is a lot more true
yeah the skin is thicker so you know if
the waffler noodles it's a much thinner
skin yeah this is more reminiscent of a
ravioli I mean I've never had like a
dumpling like this before the ravioli
catcher so like a chew and a bite to it
yeah the sweet sauce on this it's [ __ ]
yeah you could put this [ __ ] on anything
yeah right yo man come out to this
restaurant this is this is some
next-level [ __ ] dude Jonathan Gold man
I'm telling you bro you know what's up
I'm gonna go [ __ ] out something later in
a little bit this place is great I love
it I love it it's great to Asian people
this is not a disgrace to Asian people
have you seen a Japanese samurais
like that Ninja Turtle something right
that is that are you called stop wearing
fake shoes hey excuse me this is a part
of Asian culture do you not support
crazy rich Asians
[Applause]
don't use wool shoe for aggression and
violence okay like Bruce Lee once said
be like water I can't do this so get rid
of your face that's worse it's getting
worse and I'll slap it okay and now I'm
so happy oh so much joy yeah whose shoes